what are interesting differences in
culture if you can comment on between
Google Dropbox and Microsoft from our
Python Programming perspective all
places you've been to the positive
is there a difference or is it just
about people and there's great people
everywhere or is there culture
differences
so if Dropbox is much smaller than the
other two in your list yeah so that's
death is a big difference the set of
products they provide is more it's
narrower so they're more focused
yeah and and Dropbox sort of at least
during the time I was there
had the tendency of sort of
making a big plan putting the whole
company behind that plan for a year and
then evaluate and then suddenly find
that
everything was wrong about the plan and
then they had to do something completely
different and so there were there was
like
the annual engineering reorg was was
sort of an unpleasant Tradition at
Dropbox because like oh there's a new VP
of engineering and so now all the
directors are being reshuffled and this
guy was in charge of of
infrastructure one year and the next
year he was made in charge of I don't
know product development
it's fascinating because like you don't
think about these companies internally
but I you know Dropbox to me from the
very beginning was one of my favorite uh
Services there's certain like programs
and online services that
make me happy make me more efficient and
all that kind of stuff but one of the
powers of those kinds of services they
disappear they you're not supposed to
think about how it all works but it's
incredible to me that you can sync stuff
effortlessly
across so many machines so quickly and
like don't have to worry about conflicts
they they take care of the you know as a
person that comes from version
repositories and all that kind of stuff
or merge is super difficult and uh just
keeping different versions different
files is very tricky the fact that they
could take care of that is just that I
don't know the the engineering behind
the scenes must be super difficult both
on the computer infrastructure and the
software a lot of internal sort of
hand-wringing about things like that but
the the product itself always worked
very smoothly and yeah it does but
there's probably a lot of lessons to
that you can have a lot of turmoil
inside on the engineering side but If
the product is good the product is good
and don't maybe don't mess with that
either you know when it's good
keep it's like with Google focus on the
search and the ads
right like and the money will come yeah
and make sure that's done extremely well
and don't forget what you do extremely
well in in what ways do you provide
value and happiness to the world make
sure you do that well
um is there something else to say about
Google and Microsoft Microsoft has said
a very fascinating shift recently with a
new CEO uh what you know recent CEO with
purchasing GitHub
embracing open source culture embracing
the developer culture is pretty
interesting to see that's like why I
joined Microsoft
I mean after after retiring and thinking
that I would stay retired for the rest
of my life which of course was a
ridiculous thought but that I was I was
I was done working for a bit and then
the pandemic made me realize that work
work can also provide a source of
fulfillment
keep keep you out of trouble
uh Microsoft is a very interesting
company because it has this incredible
very long and varied history and this
amazing catalog of products that many of
which also date way back
I mean
I've been been talking to a bunch of
excel people lately and Excel is like 35
years old yeah and they can still read
spreadsheets that that they might find
on an old floppy Drive
yeah there's man they've built so many
incredible tools through the years
Excel one of the great shames of my life
is that I've never learned how to use
Excel well I mean it just always felt
like so many features are there it's
similar with IDs like pie charm
it feels like I I converge quickly to
the dumbest way to use a thing to get
the job done when clearly there's so
much more power at your fingertips
yeah but there's I I do think there's
probably expert users of Excel and oh
that Excel is a cash cow actually oh it
actually brings in money oh yeah a lot
of the engineering sort of if you look
deep inside Excel
there's some very good engineering very
very impressive stuff
okay now I need to definitely learn it's
a little better I had issues because I'm
a keyboard person so I had issues coming
up with shortcuts I mean Microsoft
sometimes
uh it's changed over the years but
sometimes they kind of want to make
things easier for you on the surface and
therefore make it harder for like uh
people that like to have shortcuts and
all that kind of stuff to optimize their
workflow now Excel is probably people
are probably yelling at me and it's like
no Excel probably has a lot of ways to
optimize work in fact I keep discovering
that there are many features in Excel
that only exists at keyboard shortcuts
yeah that's the sense I have and now
like I'm embarrassed that it's just you
just have to know what they are yeah
that's that's like there's no logic or
or Reason to the assignment of the
keyboard shortcuts because they they go
back even longer than 35 years
can you maybe comment about Sachin Adela
and how hard it is for CEO to sort of
pivot a company towards open source
towards developer culture is there
something you could see about like how
what's the role of leadership in such a
pivot in definition of a new vision I've
never met him but uh I hear
he's just a really sharp
thinker
but he also has an incredible business
sense
he took the organization that had very
solid pieces but that was also
struggling
with all sorts of shameful things
especially the Steve Ballmer time
I imagine in part through his personal
charm and thinking and of course the the
great trust that that the the rest of
the leadership has in him he managed to
to Really Turn the company around and
sort of
change it from from openly hostile to
open source
to to actively embracing open source and
that doesn't mean that suddenly Excel is
going to go open source but that means
that there's room for a product like vs
code which is open source
yeah it's fascinating it gives me faith
that large companies with good
leadership can grow can expand can
change and pivot and so on develop uh
because it gets harder and harder as the
company gets large